we got our guy tom curran nbc sports
boston tom give me a number from 1 to 10
10 being the most surprised that you
were when you saw that jones was there
and that the patriots took him
boy uh that jones was there i would put
that at about
a nine that the patriots took them i put
that at about a 2.7
because they have a yawning need a
quarterback
a capable one who can put his hands at
ten and two and run an offense was
present
high floor possibly a relatively low
ceiling but a guy who's going to be an
improvement in the position of need so
to me it's not a stunner it does
surprise me that they didn't have to
give up a single thing and they let the
draft come to them guys
do you think that they were prepared to
give up something for mac jones i don't
know whether it would have been to get
the 10 or whatever it happened to have
been
i i don't think that they were
i really don't i don't think that they
loved all five quarters actually i know
they didn't love all five quarterbacks
so
my guess is it went lawrence
wilson
jones
then fields then lance that was my guess
and when lance went see here's the
interesting thing about the whole
situation with with san francisco and
trey lance once lance goes do you know
that jimmy garoppolo has to stay
almost certainly through 2021 because
tray lance is not going to be an
experienced enough player to lead a
super bowl caliber office or team so you
have to keep garoppolo so now he's
eliminated as a patriots opportunity to
fall from the quarterback tree
and you kind of have your hands tied
if you don't go with matt jones
you're quite likely going into the
season with cam newton and jared stidham
and a lesser player so we got some
tuners around here
sorry would they have brought garoppolo
back yeah i heard that would they have
brock garoppolo back i'm thinking about
my next question though would they have
brought him back because jermaine
wiggins had the comment from a few weeks
ago on weei that there's some guys on
the team that looked at him funny
because he can't stay healthy and we saw
in san francisco he can't stay healthy
would they have brought him back and
what price would they have paid below
the 25 million he was due to make this
year
they would 100 percent have brought him
back absolutely i don't know who would
be looking at scans adam any more than
than we do i still think that he's got a
demonstrable level of play that he has
when he is
healthy that you can say that's that's
workable that's between seven and and
fourteen on the quarterback scale in the
nfl that's where i would put them and
that's probably what mac jones will be
at best but to me they probably would
have had to get i would say almost a
half
the salary buyback mike wouldn't they
because bill belichick's not going to
spend
15
of the cap
on jimmy garoppolo oft injured and cam
newton not the world's greatest thrower
and say this is this is something i like
doing i just don't think that would have
happened
well i tend to agree with you there tom
i mean that's something we've been
talking about for ages just the fact
that jimmy garoppolo's salary makes it
probably pretty hard for him to be
traded at least uh as it is currently
constructed but i don't want to ask you
this about matt jones i mean is the
saban connection with belichick really
one of the reasons why this is something
that could happen that he would that
belichick was so interested in jones is
like if if matt jones were john smith
and he played at texas do you think that
they still would have had the same
amount of interest
this was the safest pick you could make
bill belichick in terms and that's the
interesting thing so
in years gone by yes i think that if he
liked matt jones from texas
who i
have said he's going to be called mccoy
and maybe if cole mccoy came to the
patriots he'd be a pro ball player too
um
because it matters where you land
and that's why matt jones is probably
going to have a better year than zach
wilson
regardless he's probably going to be
more successful this year than zach
wilson because of where he landed but
you know when the owner
takes the bait on the conference call
and says we have to draft better
and he just spent a quarter billion
dollars
on overall contracts 172 and guaranteed
and he also says on the same conference
call we have to get a clear
and solidified opportunity at the
quarterback position or solidify the
quarterback position
you're kind of in a band-aid
and i think that bill said all right
well we got a guy who knows he can get
his ass cheered by a hard coach he's not
dumb
he's got an acceptable level of play
and we need the guy so let's just take
him
when the oddsmakers put out the number
of starts over under for mac jones
eight and a half
six and a half
three and a half ten and a half what's
it gonna be
i was gonna say eight mike
i was gonna say eight
because here's the thing cam newton is
going to be better in 2021
he's not going to have coven during the
year and i know that i think that was a
little bit of a red herring that the
patriots and cam newton um were happy to
embrace he wasn't covet affected when he
was short-hopping receivers in december
but he's gonna have a full training camp
he is going to be and it's not going to
be prompted the same way that i think
you know aaron rodgers was prompted or
um tom brady was prompted by a draftee
but i think the camel have a little fire
lit under him to prove something here
um and he's going to compete i think
he'll start the season as the patriots
quarterback but there will be a time
when i think his body will prevent him
from getting the ball to the hunter
henry's and johnny smith's
and running the offense the way cam
could and should and they'll say okay
we're going to put the other guy in
you just went 13 for 28
and we barely won that game so you're
out
it just seems that sometimes you know we
talk about patriots offense and its
complexities and all that do you think
that jones is going to really benefit
from just basically having the off
season
getting that chance that opportunity to
learn the offense in the off season
before he has to start really trying to
implement it because obviously once the
regular season starts you just don't get
the reps
no and that's why jared stidham
i keep getting this replayed on me all
the time too today a couple weeks ago i
also not just the mac jones to colt
mccoy comparison i said the patriots
already have matt jones on the roster
his name's jared stidham
garrett stidham still hasn't had an off
season really his second off season went
to auburn and baylor and didn't have nfl
ready offenses mac jones has so he's
already got a leg up i think mack jones
does
but
the interesting thing is with the
sophistication of the patriots offense
that is in its totality there's no
reason the entire book has to be thrown
at anyone and it wasn't with cam newton
and there were sections of the book that
were put to the front because it was cam
and there were sections that were put in
the back because it wasn't jimmy and it
wasn't tom brady so we'll see which fun
from the book they're working off of but
it's going to be really interesting to
see is it's a great question miles
how do you have two very different style
quarterbacks
show their best
in july august and september
to make the decision as to who's going
to run this team that they spent so much
money on and should be able to micro
right contend
not just in their division but in the
afc
where do they go from here in the draft
corner offensive tackle wide receiver
those are the places i think need
addressing
um and to uh i think edge they could
they could use somebody to make an offer
an offensive coordinator and a couple of
tackles start to sweat a little bit more
than they do on the way to the games
would they rather get one more let me
let me ask him another one miles i'm
sorry
well because i'll forget if i don't ask
it now would they rather get tom brady
early in the year or late in the year
i think i've asked you this before but i
but i really do think they they'd have a
preference
when do you think it would be
i think their preference would
be late in the year especially with
the fact that bill belichick i mean the
patriots oftentimes i used to say
columbus day
the patriots in the last few years have
not declared themselves until closer to
thanksgiving and that includes that 2018
season when they last won the super bowl
they were
boy i can't i think they were five and
five five and four six and five and then
they went on a tear down the stretch so
uh later in the year they would prefer
i'm sure
um
and plus bring all those guys up into
the cold and have fun up here
all right well speaking of tv 12 since
he he got brought up and then we're
showing his highlights there don't don't
you feel like these mac jones tom brady
comparisons like they got to stop like
this it just seems like it's too much
don't mind see you're you're right it
has to stop because all of it is fair
from the body type
to the
mild underdog status while in college
but
tom brady became tom brady from 2000 to
2006 when he looked at drew bledsoe and
said
he can't outwork me he's got a wife he's
got three kids he's got responsibilities
he's fat happy and has a hundred million
dollar contract i want those things
so will matt jones be prompted the same
way tom brady does
too many
the cigar is even better than that one
too many nipples
i mean there's gonna be an over under on
your show for nipples and that's four of
them right there
uh
but that to me is the greatest
difference between everybody can play
like tom brady did
but are you going to be that maniacal
and weird to the level that he has been
to have your entire life and all your
cells and dna revolve around it mike too
you gotta stop there is no julian
edelman come back coming
but
did you see that i don't think there is
either but did you see tom brady last
night joking about it and
and like
there was a little bit of a glint of
truth in what tom brady said let's go
ahead and let's go ahead and have a
listen and then we can get your thoughts
on whether you believe it
we know we know julian didn't retire
he's just people he's just too scared
he's too scared to tell bill he wanted
to come to the tampa
guys guys is julian has his hair stuck
like i've been there no i i i see it's
uh it's it's spring time for the bradys
because he's got his little uh sailing
stripes on and
you know enjoying that wonderful weather
out in florida
and later kevin hart asked him point
blank whether or not he
is just doing all this to set up his
return and he kind of gave a
tongue-in-cheek response yeah i don't
think he's coming back
but
i didn't think rob gronkowski was coming
back either tom
i know
and i guess on the surface it makes
sense to compare the two
but the relationship between gronkowski
and the patriots and edelman and the
patriots are
south pole north pole i mean they could
not be any more different i mean
belichick bent over backwards to make
sure that edelman was ushered into
retirement with all the benefits and
realized as much of his money as he
could edelman's body gave out he just
can't do anymore grunk
was sick of the being
pressured to practice julian practiced
as much as he could um his body's done
they can't so
i'll shave an eyebrow mic i'll shave an
eyebrow if he comes
back oh well you know i don't want to
see that i don't want to see that i'm
not willing to take that action i don't
want to see you without an eyebrow
take that action
well come up with something we'll shave
it
all right
tom we appreciate some of your time i i
hope you're parked in a safe spot i
remember the time we did this and you
were like on the side of the road and
trucks were whizzing by so good to see
good to see that you're safe and good to
see you as always enjoy the rest of the
draft and we'll talk to you real soon
where are you where are you anyway
i'm uh
wow i would say i'm eight miles from
gillette uh on my way to the office and
i'm in a dunkin donuts parking lot in
norwood mess see and there's the donkeys
right there
drive safely have fun enjoy the draft
we'll talk soon
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports